is a fox news alert a rapidly
deteriorating situation
violence and chaos breaking out all over
in the nation of south africa
fox's trace gallagher has the very
latest of the sad story for us
right now trace and tucker it's
impossible not to draw
parallels of what's happening right now
in south africa and what happened here
in the u.s after the death of george
floyd
and what could easily happen again in
this country when police are
outnumbered and overwhelmed this video
is from the kwazulu-natal province where
a mall is engulfed in flames
and rioters are dominating the police
presence there
you can also see looters going down the
road with boxes
filled with goods piled up on trucks
dollies carts
even a tractor now police are firing
what appear to be rubber bullets at the
larger groups
and get this witnesses say even armed
south african citizens were firing on
people in the street though
it's unclear how many if any of them
were hit
and watch and listen to what's happening
in soweto
[Applause]
and remember the context here this is
supposed to be a protest about south
africa's former president jacob zuma
being imprisoned for contempt of court
and yet crowds of people are using it as
an opportunity to steal everything from
furniture
to electrical appliances and now look at
south africa's most
popular populist province of guantang
where there is astonishing video of
rioters and looters
running inside a popular shopping center
carrying bags and other items and again
police are pointing weapons at the
looters but it's a total mismatch
and just like we saw in america south
africa small business owners and the
poor
are bearing the brunt of this because
their businesses have been destroyed and
critical public services like
electricity and water have been
disruptive
so far we have confirmed 10 people have
been killed in the chaos
that number will almost certainly rise
tucker
chris gallagher thanks so much we're
going to much more on what's happening
in south africa
tomorrow and possibly the day after
assuming it continues the links between
this country and south africa are deep
and profound particularly politically
our ruling class did a lot to empower
the current government
of south africa there may be lessons for
the world in what's happening there one
of the lessons is that when
chaos strikes you're on your own hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else